what's up guys bang bang this video is
brought to you by prime xbt
they are a crypto trading platform that
has an excellent award-winning
environment for margin trading if you
want to go check out
their crypto trading be sure to check
out their copy trading module which
allows you to replicate the trades of
the most successful traders with a
proven track record
if you're interested you can register
with the link below and you can get a
50 deposit bonus go check them out at
prime
xbt and let's get into this interview
all right guys bang bang super excited
to have both james and eric here thank
you guys so much for doing this
thank you for having us so maybe let's
just get started with each one of you
kind of going over your background and
then what you guys focus on a day-to-day
basis
uh sure i'll start so my background is i
started as a reporter
um for institutional investor in the
late 90s covering derivatives but then i
got
put to mutual funds and so i wrote i
wrote for a newsletter there
and then i wanted to go on the other
side of the keyhole so i went to pr for
a while
i i was jealous pr people seem to have a
seat at the table
like you get to the big table quicker in
pr and i i went there and you do you
meet a lot of uh
higher ups and it's interesting um and
so i did pr and then i got a job at
bloomberg npr which was exciting uh got
a little bit interaction with mike
bloomberg and that was great and got to
learn the company really well
and then um i had a near miss in in 2001
so you know 911 and then went to work
down in princeton i moved from manhattan
to south jersey and did a life change
and i worked at a princeton the only
thing i did there was data
and so i'm this pr guy going into data
which is
i think i'm still the only bloomberg
employee who made that that shift
normally people start in data and then
go into more exciting areas
and move to new york um i did the
opposite and
but it was what i needed it and i got to
learn how the terminal was made and they
put me in the funds data area because i
had that background
so i spent 15 years helping to build the
bloomberg funds database
but i was able to use some of my
communication skills uh in
interesting ways down there and so part
of that led to
getting data better articulating
why trends were happening in the data
and becoming like an analyst and then
etfs were something that was rising
around 2005
2006 they got big in 2008 they really
started to get big
and so i got assigned to cover those and
so i built out the database adding etf
style fields
and then ultimately i got poached
internally from our research group
to actually write research and sort of
lead an etf research team
with uh which has a couple people on it
including james and so
our main job is to write i call them
mcnugget research reports like you know
the sell side will write like this huge
thing
and maybe put it out once a month uh we
have to run in guns so we do like
mcnugget maybe three little notes a week
if you added up our monthly production
it would look like one of those reports
but we just put them out quickly
and luck if we're lucky they get on top
go they get some reads and it's really
premium content for the terminal clients
and then we try to brand it and market
it we do what we have a podcast we do
some tv hits um
and then uh that's essentially the job
it's quality production
and you know getting your uh name and
making noise about what you wrote you
have to sort of do that on your own
and that's sort of what we spend our
week doing and then the rest of time is
idea flow which is why we use twitter
and talk to people um is getting
feedback and trying to get our
keep our ear to the ground so when we
write about this stuff we're we're right
on the
you know we want to catch swells before
they become waves and so that's
that's generally our you know that's my
day job in a nutshell
yeah so um i i i started in bloomberg
data
uh right out of college um i started in
the funds department covering etfs and
hedge funds
um built up was the main person covering
that area when eric went over to
research
for the most part uh so eric made that
jump and then i was the one
uh maintaining the database on the data
side
so basically anybody looking for
information on etfs we were maintaining
that information
and then eric pulled me over to join him
on the research side of things and i
worked with him and actually mike
mcglone
who is our commodity strategist and in
2017 i i had personal interest in crypto
i had been following it for a little bit
of
time and mcglone basically decided that
he was going to start covering crypto
under the commodity side of things
because it was getting so big and there
was so much coverage and we needed to
have some sort of reference rate to
cover it so
um me and a colleague at kevin kelly
helped bring mike up to speed and
at this point he's passed me in actual
crypto knowledge he's on technical sides
of things but uh
so now i i primarily write about etfs
with eric and uh there's a few subsets
and one of the subsets i cover is
uh the crypto space so a lot of coverage
on whether or not a bitcoin etf is going
to come out and
these uh these trusts from grayscale and
bitwise and other things
absolutely and so for those that are
just listening and not watching uh eric
spoke first and james spoke seconds that
you can
uh kind of uh calibrate whose voice is
who
but uh so what i want to talk about
today is basically public market
exposure to
crypto assets right and uh maybe what i
thought we could start with
uh is if one of you could just walk
through what is the
kind of thought process or the
advantages for having just public market
exposure in general versus
private market exposure or going to uh
some of the crypto exchanges so kind of
having regulated
you know more traditional public market
exposure uh
via either the current products or
future prices we'll talk about what's
kind of that argument as to why that's
an important part of the portfolio
yeah i mean i'll take a first step and
then pass it to james for the crypto
angle but
in general i would use the word
convenience
i think and democratization i mean when
you put something in an etf or a mutual
fund
um future's a little different but let's
just say mutual funds and etfs
anybody can buy it and etfs in
particular because they trade on
uh brokerage platforms so just like you
can buy microsoft they
see them in the tickers on cnbc as well
and so um
i remember when bill gross came out this
etf he said it so it was you know his
mom could buy it uh
you know so there's a lot of uh uh
democratization but the convenience i
mean
you know cryptos is probably an ultimate
example of the convenience that an etf
could bring to it
but like even the s p 500 you know the
stocks i mean you could
replicate that all day and save the nine
basis points but most people are
fine paying state street nine basis
points or vanguard three whatever
to get somebody to do that for them and
so i think that's
generally if i had to just keep it
simple it's convenience
and it's just also an ability to get uh
anybody
access i don't know if james you have
anything to add or read crypto in that
regard
yeah i will say like the the ease of i
mean
people can hold crypto with square and
all that there's tons of different
options to do it
um but that people do lose their
passwords this is very evident
i mean there's i know plenty of people i
talk to who think there's no reason to
have a bitcoin etf but i also talk to
even more people who
want nothing more than to have a bitcoin
etf so they can hold bitcoin in their
retirement accounts and whatnot um and
then versus private funds i mean the
private funds are only available to
accredited investors if you
so that ver vastly limits the population
that can get access to these things in
this manner
nothing is stopping anyone from creating
a coinbase account and getting access to
bitcoin but just having it an etf typing
a ticker
buying it holding it trading it um is
just as eric said the convenience factor
is
is through the roof and can i you know
since
um i would can i ask you a question sure
so
with the new york times article said
that there's 140 billion dollars
that stuck because people lost their
passwords
um this to me is a pretty big uh reason
to have an etf i mean
that wouldn't happen arguably unless the
company lost its password but
is that true though is that was that
correct
yeah i think that uh it's a little
misleading in the sense of
uh the short answers nobody knows for
sure in that specific article
i think they accounted for a lot of the
early
uh bitcoin that hadn't moved in you know
eight nine
uh ten years as being lost um
and every once in a while all of a
sudden one of the wallets will become
active again to suggest that obviously
somebody has control of it
so it's easy to kind of overestimate if
you just simply look and say hey we're
going to include anything that hasn't
moved in eight years
is obviously something that's been lost
i just don't think that that's
necessarily accurate
uh the problem uh with kind of uh
refuting that
is that you don't have a better answer
right it's not like oh but actually the
answer is you know x
uh so i think that it's probably um a
material number right
it's not zero uh but it's definitely not
140 billion dollars or kind of 20
or anything like that but i i think it
speaks to um
just the idea of thinking of of
remembering passwords i sometimes
struggle to get in like linkedin
sometimes like what what password i use
for this
um but i will say that the general idea
and
again it goes back to convenience uh i
use the gold etf
uh you could buy gold uh but people
don't want to pay for the you know to
insure it or secure it in their house
you know if you have a safe you can go
the whole nine yards
and they're people who should i mean
some people get a a little
touchy with the bitcoin etf concept but
i'm like no one's saying you can't do it
on your own
it's just there are certain people who
do are happy to pay for the convenience
and gold is a great example that's a 70
billion dollar fund gold by the way gld
is the
etf that got to one billion the fastest
and took
three days and that was in 2004 and
there's been
a thousand plus launches since that
tells you that i think if a bitcoin etf
comes out that's that stands the best
chance
uh to beat that record yeah i absolutely
believe
if uh an etf got approved it would not
take 72 hours to get to a billion
dollars
might have a little bit faster than that
um so maybe let's start with uh with
james let's
kind of evaluate uh not so much like the
investing merit
or or argument but more so just market
structure wise
uh the current products in the public
market and so
uh the three that come to mind
immediately uh
are the grayscale uh bitcoin trust uh
the bitwise kind of
uh crypto top ten uh index um
and then the three iq uh publicly traded
it's called the bitcoin fund uh in
canada are those the
main three in your opinion or are there
other ones that uh that
you kind of pay attention to and spend
time on so grayscale has a whole slew of
them they have a litecoin one
they have a bitcoin cash one they have
their own digital large cap one um
but grayscale the e and then grayscale
also has ethg so
the ethereum one so ethg gbtc
uh both from grayscale are two of the
the two big ones
uh bitwise is a new one on the block
it's pretty big as well and then
you said qbtc in canada also very big so
those are definitely the the main ones
we're watching but we're
we have a if you have a terminal you can
see some of this stuff
um i'll tweet about it but we're
monitoring this constantly looking at
the flows looking at the assets looking
how much trading is happening these
things but
the the market structure is such that we
truly believe that
the fact that these are operating the
way that they are operating should be a
reason the sec should be considering
launching etf so what happens here is
one to create shares it's just it's kind
of like a hedge fund
you have to be an accredited investor in
all of these um
or at least the us ones and uh you
create shares at the value of the
underlying assets so you're getting
what's known as nav net asset on net
asset value so the
whatever the value of the holdings are
and then you
you have a lock-up period whether it's
12 months or six months which can change
but you if you're an accredited investor
you create their shares
those shares then go and can trade on
the secondary exchange otc or over the
counter
and the problem here is that that price
where they trade over the exchange could
be
vastly different from the underlying
value of the holdings you're getting
so for example ethg the ethereum trust
was trading over 200 percent in december
it's now trading at three percent so
you're you're seeing these massive
swings in the price of these actual
trusts that
are not in line with the value of
ethereum so basically
as ethereum balloon from december into
uh january i don't know what the exact
percentage is but
it's almost sixteen hundred dollars now
i mean you
your your ethereum trust if you held the
graceful ethereum trust you're you're
down
you actually went down because the the
compression there
now as some of these mature uh gbtc has
matured the premium has gone down a lot
but there's still significant risk for
retail traders or investors to get in
and not get a
a fair price that's equivalent to what
they're actually buying
yeah i mean i think the idea that an etf
can create and destroy
shares it's called the creation
redemption process is it i call it it's
sort of like the flux capacitor in back
to the future
it really is how etfs uh work so well
and they really tap into the power
centers and market makers of wall street
so
uh they're able to arbitrage and so
arbitrage sounds like a like a dirty
word to a lot of people but it's really
beneficial and
arb is is really channeling the
self-interest
of people to make money to help it have
a price close to the nav because if it
veers away
it'll get armed that constant arb is
great because if you're you know like
the kelly blue book value
of a car is you want to get a price to
close that bitcoin will
go up and down i mean i think most
people are okay with that they just
don't want to get
uh surprised and you know there was
something called closed end funds
i'm sure some people on this have heard
of it but that's why clothesline funds
got like sort of left on the
evolutionary
uh you know they're like roadkill on the
evolutionary line of funds
some people use them there's some
interesting things going on with them
but uh for the most part they kind of
got
uh killed when the etf came out because
they'd have that problem
and the other thing is this for the sec
and the gbtc
issue i think they had a better case to
ignore when it had like a billion
dollars
and it was like yeah it's this tiny
little thing over there but we just did
the math um
gbtc if it were an etf would be in the
top one percent
in volume assets and flows so
and this isn't this isn't even trading
on any exchange and so
people are finding it some people think
it's an etf
and we just think that at this point now
it's become like
a big reason that the sec should
consider an etf
uh in you know sooner rather than later
so
uh and either one of you can take this
but basically this idea of trading at a
premium right eric you just described
like it would be in the top 1
and if an etf was the vehicle of choice
there is a creation
and a redemption function or kind of a
creation and destruction of shares
these trust structures my understanding
is that they have no
redemption function there is no
destruction function and so
what basically happens is uh if i go and
i invest at nav
in the private placement i put in you
know a million dollars they go they buy
a million dollars with a bitcoin
i got a million dollars of shares i have
to hold it illiquid for
six to twelve months depending on the
vehicle uh and then once
my kind of illiquid hold period expires
i can then go sell it in the public
market
when i do that that's where you're
experiencing all kinds of volatility on
that premium to the nav
is that ultimately because there's no
destruction function or no redemption
function that's where the nav is
actually being
uh kind of or i'm sorry the premium is
being created is that how that works
yeah so everything you said is correct
um
the only one thing most of the creations
from what i understand are actually in
kind so people are actually going out
and buying bitcoin or ethereum and
handing it to grayscale essentially
and then they're getting their shares in
return but this it's not there
there's no redemption if there was no
redemption that would cause discounts
more that but that's also an issue
the real issue is that they can't create
shares fast enough so even if we created
enough shares to meet demand so the
price fell in line directly with the nav
today
there's that six month 12 month lock-up
right so
they the shares don't actually meet that
demand whereas an etf the shares would
be created and then they're available to
trade
that day and what happens is the the
market makers are going to constantly be
creating or destroying shares
to keep that price in line so if the
price is higher they're going to sell
the price by the nav
and and vice versa and is it fair to say
that uh that's simply just by using the
trust structure
obviously uh bitwise where i'm an
investor and then
uh grayscale uh which i know those guys
pretty well they've essentially
chosen these platform uh kind of
products right or these fun structures
really at a necessity like they can't go
get the etf approved and therefore this
is the next best thing and so that's why
they're using it
yeah absolutely and i maybe i came off a
little judgy towards gbtc um i do
believe there's etf would be a much
better way to do it but
i don't really judge them for it because
at least it's a way to trade bitcoin
in a way that's how much people are
dying for this convenient rapper
um and i know some people who are really
smart i can't say their names but
they know crypto and they use this so if
they're using it knowing all of this in
full knowledge i think that speaks to
demand it also speaks to the fact that
they'll you know they're just okay to
stomach that pretty then by the way the
premium could work in your favor
there are times when you could just get
an extra 20
return because the premium went up uh so
it's not like all bad there is a
positive side to that the problem is
just the potential for a nasty surprise
in somebody who doesn't know that
um where they they lose money even
though bitcoin get you
you know you don't want to bet on
something have it work out for you and
then lose money that makes no sense
um so and this is why you see other
people launching um these
uh trusts that trade over the counter
it's just the only way to do it for now
and
um you know yeah i guess i'll leave it
there james you have anything
on top yeah so that i i will say bitwise
is actually in the process of getting
their own bitcoin trust so right now
they have the bitwise 10 so
the trading otc we don't know the ticker
yet for the
um the bitcoin version but that should
be coming online in otc in the next few
months or
month or two um the other thing i would
say is as eric pointed out gbtc
grayscale all these guys are
doing the best at what the sec is
allowing them to do they're trying to
give this access
if we're up to grayscale i'm sure they
would have launched an etf already
um and the other thing is the reason
they don't allow redemption is the
the sec issued a cease and desist letter
so like they stopped greyscale from
allowing this red
their rejections to occur so it's not
like grayscale is like doing this on
their own and they're saying we're not
going to allow people to take money out
um and and gbtc it really is the best
vehicle like if you're a traditional
financial brokerage system right so
you're an advisor and you want to put
your client in bitcoin
without learning how to deal with
bitcoin which we can argue how easy or
hard that is
this is the easiest way to get access to
this nutritional
traditional financial ecosystem right if
you want an on-ramp
this is the way to do it if you're if
you're a mutual fund or etf you want
access to bitcoin
gbtc is the easiest way to do it we've
seen it at kathy wood from arc this is
how she got access
and if you have a brokerage account you
have an ira a retirement account you
want to get access to bitcoin
i've read about other ways that you can
do it but the easiest simplest way to do
it is buying gbtc and that's evidence
why there is a premium you could argue
there's a premium for a reason whether
it's the convenience
or the ability to get access in this way
so i we don't want to sound like we're
dissing gbtc or any of these products
they are doing what
they're allowed to do they're doing the
best they can yeah and my understanding
is that they probably if the etf did get
approved they would just convert the
trust
into an etf right like they would just
say hey look we know the etf has the
better structure we would like to have
an etf we're not allowed to today this
is the best
option we have and so if there's etf
approvals then we'll just convert into
that etf structure
absolutely that would be their goal and
this is where the sec if they do
move forward and decide to do it they
kind of have a
a little bit of a conundrum here on who
to approve first
because if you approved a bitcoin etf
that wasn't them
you're probably going to have that
premium just people would exit that fund
go into the new etf and anyone who was
just
not aware of what's going on would
definitely lose money and like gamestop
style
in in that one so that's where they
probably need to
i guess if i was running the sec i would
probably allow them to convert at the
same time but then that's not fair
because then all of a sudden now they
have all this
assets where they launched this thing
kind of
in a way ahead of time i don't know the
etf industry is riddled with
people who have been benefited from
asking for forgiveness rather than
permission
we saw it with the pod etf i won't go
into the details but i could see that
happening
um and just one thing back to the
premium the premium is
is bad and it's a 10 right now i just
looked but it's been as high as 100
now everybody would go 100 is crazy 10
not bad but we're in an etf industry
right now where
advisors are literally like they'll move
into one etf because it's a couple basis
points cheaper
so that 10 means a lot and if you go to
europe they have etfs
etns and etfs over there that use the
arbitrage mechanism and they're they're
pretty good and the percent
premium and discount looks to be about
one percent up or down
so that and that's using europe and
that's an etn you imagine us market
makers i would estimate maybe you're
looking at 50 basis points
and that's just essentially what you're
paying the middleman
for the arbitrage they need to make a
little cut like a vague in
in sports betting but that would is not
bad
compared to 10 so again that's why we're
talking about even at 10
premium if you're talking 50 basis
points you can see the marked
improvement
on an etf uh especially in an era where
basis points
in fees are a big deal to most people
yeah and as eric kind of pointed out
hinted at
these these companies trying to launch
this they're spending a lot
of time and money trying to get a
bitcoin etf launch
so um they they all want to be first or
at least near the front
now as far as gbtc converting two things
one
right now there's no redemptions so if
they allowed redemptions that would
likely limit some of the discount
potential that could happen if an etf is
approved
so maybe they don't allow gbt to convert
immediately but they allow redemptions
that could possibly
uh help the situation the other side of
this is i've talked to some people i'm
in your camp i think gbtc would converge
just because they want to have good
faith with their
investors and their clients and whatnot
but you could argue that they're just
like they have a good annuity here right
the money's not allowed to leave they
don't have to allow money to leave
they have 22 billion dollars for
charging two percent a year right now
that's like a couple hundred million
dollars
of money that they're taking in every
year so you could argue that that why
not just launch a bitcoin etfs separate
from gbtc
um i personally don't think that'll
happen just because the pr
nightmare that wouldn't sue from it
potentially from investors but there's
there's a case to be made that
gbtc might not convert but i'm in your
camp i think they will yeah
eventually got it and so maybe let's
talk a little bit just about like
why is the sec uh not approved in etf so
far
is it uh something that has to do with
price has to do with fake volume
has to do with uh they just don't want
to be the
sec commissioners that are kind of on
the hook when an etf gets approved
uh just kind of what's the understanding
there
i mean it's it's honestly all of the
above
um i i actually just went through and
read again the denial letter they just
sent to bitwise and i looked at some of
the stuff they sent to vanek who is
another issue
we're trying to launch this the main the
main reason that they're denying is is
oversight and manipulation so they're
they're saying there's not enough
oversight in the underlying market from
regulators to like
if anything does go wrong there's no way
to know exactly how it went wrong
or who did x y or z which honestly
that's the only one on here that i think
is like somewhat viable
of a reason for them denying it in my
opinion um the other thing that they're
worried about manipulation of the
underlying market
um i just i i can't get behind them
saying that after what we just saw with
gme
really stop that never happens in stocks
yeah i mean
the amount of like manipulation that
happens in regular markets like the fact
that that's a reason to deny this
um is just crazy to me the other thing
they talk about
is the real versus fake volume which i'm
sure anyone who's involved in the crypto
space has probably seen bitwise
presentation but if not they basically
make the case that
95 percent of the volume and bitcoin is
fake
by spoofing and wash trading and all
these things um
and that is i mean
if you talk to most people that that's
just something that's been accepted in
the marketplace like we know a lot of
the volume is fake
and the sec is concerned saying that
that fake volume could affect the
the true market value of the bitcoin
that they're they're holding like how
they market their navs
so basically they're worried about
saying what the actual nav is the
underlying value of the bitcoin that's
being held
which again i push back and i say you're
not worried about that with fixed income
products i mean
not to get too far down the financial
financial hole but
in march we saw bonds that didn't trade
for weeks and days
we saw funds with navs basically saying
what these bonds were worth
completely divergent from what some of
the other things were trading at because
they simply hadn't traded so
if they're worried about accurate navs
then they need to do something about
fixed income navs as far as i'm
concerned
um and then the other thing yeah that's
really it it's all of that but it comes
back to oversight and manipulation
um and oversight i think is a fair
concern because it's a whole hodgepodge
of different
regulators and whether or not like
coinbase and gemini are registered with
the
new york state department of financial
services and all these different things
so
i can kind of understand their concerns
there but versus like some of the other
products they have approved and versus
the way that these other products
operate i just can't i
personally believe they should
ultimately approve a bitcoin etf
underneath just um i want to jump in on
the other products there's a product
that i find i keep thinking about
besides gld
that the sec approved which is ashr it
it tracks china a shares which for a
time you could not get in fact the etf
was approved when the only way to get
eight shares was through like a broker
in hong kong
and so the premiums and discounts were
pretty wide on this thing they were
upwards of five six percent
um and then the chinese government uh
halton shares
like you talk about a market that you
could manipulate the chinese government
can just shut things down
you know whenever it wants really and so
there was premiums and discounts there
over time though having the etf i think
actually brought attention and
market makers to it and helped and i
think they would do the same with
bitcoin you would be bringing in
the richest best most uh well-aware
market makers and they're not going to
mess around with exchanges that are
playing games
uh so i think that's almost a way to
police the situation or clean it up a
little is by unleashing all of those
people
but the bigger deal i think is pr um all
that is uh what james said is
is matters but it's all related to my
opinion pr there was a big
etf called xiv i don't know if you i'm
sure you held it and you had fun trading
it back in the day
maybe you didn't but a lot of people
bought that it was inverse fix futures
and um it had a it went down like 90 in
two days
and it was a big thing that was in the
new york times target managers were
trading it it was sort of like the
gamestop incident and
that i think spooked them as well as
approving a bunch of 3x etfs over the
years
so i think uh the application for the
bitcoin etf came at a bad time i think
the sec was pulling back it was
liberal 15 years ago i thought and now
it's become a little more conservative
but there is some new blood coming in
now that might uh change the situation
got it talk a little bit about the
institutional interest that you guys
believe is out there and maybe you can
caveat it with just kind of the
conversations we don't need names but
just the types of institutions
uh or or folks who consume a lot of the
content that you guys are creating and
the work that you do
and just what you're hearing from folks
uh on wall street or at some of these
financial institutions in terms of
uh maybe bitcoin and crypto in general
and then also specifically folks who are
waiting for the etf to get approved
uh maybe before they actually get the
exposure that they're seeking
yeah i'll take that one um and so i i
don't wanna so i do have some primary
knowledge
talking with some of our clients that
are interested in this i have a lot of
secondary knowledge talking with people
more in tune with the bitcoin markets
people at these companies trying to
launch these types of funds dealing with
institutions but
uh it's definitely wide-ranging i mean
in the news we've seen michael saylor
uh talk about their stuff different
people adding it to their treasuries
um i mean i've def i've personally dealt
with private equity funds and family
offices
asking me questions about these these
products these trust products the us
these grayscale products
um and there there's people pouring
money into them i mean gbtc has
over 20 billion dollars in assets right
now i mean that's not nothing and that's
not just
that's not retail investors almost none
of it is because you have to be an
accredited investor
to invest in those things but the other
side of this is some of the demand
in these products also has to do with
the way the structure
is laid out there i've talked to
multiple clients who are institutions
that are
investing in these things some obviously
investing because i believe long term
a lot of them both because they believe
long term but also because they want to
take advantage of those premiums i
talked about so what they'll do is
they might create shares in some of
these trusts they'll hedge out the
underlying exposure
and basically all they're doing is
betting on that premium and they're
hoping that in six months
they can sell and all of a sudden that's
risk that's that's a profit whatever the
premium is is the profit they make
some of them hedge out half their
exposure some obviously hedge out none
um but institutions are flowing to these
products specifically because of those
premiums for now so i'd be interested to
see how that continues if an etf
launches do we stop seeing the flows
going
where an etf gets approved do we stop
seeing flows go into these products the
way we have the last year or so
yeah one of the other things that uh i'm
personally fascinated by i have no clue
how this would uh kind of sequentially
play out
but um obviously all of the public
market exposure that we're talking about
here
is on regulated exchanges based in the
united states
and really it would come from uh you
know the sec approval
and kind of all the market structure
surveillance like all the things that
we've talked about
and we know kind of go on these
regulated markets uh but
bitcoin and other types of
cryptocurrencies there's a kind of
almost shadow public market right and
what i
mean by that is simply you can go uh on
coinbase gemini block five kraken you
know binance
ftx whatever the exchange of your
choices uh and you can basically
buy uh in the public market rather kind
of the open market
uh these assets now it's not on a
us-based kind of stock exchange
right so you would have to sign up for a
different account there's all the
friction i think eric you were kind of
talking about the beginning
uh but what does become interesting is
if you take something like you know
bitwise's top 10 index
and now that's a token traded in the
crypto public market right kind of on an
exchange uh but not necessarily just in
the public market
uh you know in the near stock exchange
nasdaq whatever
and so do you guys have any thoughts or
any kind of insights in terms of
uh are there wall street investors who
are looking at some of these exchanges
in the
kind of crypto native world saying hey
look that's a new version of public
market exposure
or does it feel like most of them either
because of regulatory
and kind of oversight concerns or
security or whatever
they're kind of just sticking to the
main us-based regulated exchanges where
stocks trade alongside some of these
other vehicles that give you kind of
passive exposure it's definitely the
latter
um i've obviously read plenty of stories
about people trying to tokenize
even calling these tokens etfs even
though they're obviously not etfs that's
a specific term
but it might make sense down the line i
mean there's a lot of there's a
you can make the argument that things
are going to be heavily tokenized in the
future
um i just don't think we're there yet
and i think the institutions are more
inclined to get things in into the
traditional financial ecosystem as they
are currently
um so it's like an ett right like an
exchange-traded token
yes and let's take us
i will take a step back and say that i
the the bitwise 10 bit w
i i the sec so garrett we didn't really
talk about this but gary gensler is a
new sec chairman coming in
i i think ultimately we'll start getting
some of these crypto index products
approved on the traditional
exchanges that we're talking about but
it's going to be a bitcoin etf first and
that's going to have to operate smoothly
without hiccups for any for a certain
period of time before they start
allowing other
um other cryptos to trade on the
exchange in europe they have ripple and
bitcoin cash and other products that are
etfs
but i don't think the us is going to do
anything with the bitcoin product uh
anything beyond a bitcoin product to
start
uh if and when they do launch one and um
when you talk about institutions there's
a we look at the
players of the people who buy things as
institutions asset owners those are like
pensions
endowments uh family offices
and then there's advisors some people
call them institutions i would not
uh you know and those have you know the
dollar amount changes but i believe
somewhere in the ballpark of 25 trillion
that's who this is for because when we
look at etf assets
the top level of those institutions most
of them only use ets for liquidity
purposes like they'll use spy
as something they can buy or sell real
quick like a pseudo futures contract
something that's liquid and easy to get
in and out of
but for for long term they'll usually
buy it on their own they're smart enough
and they can do it on their own and
sometimes they can do it cheaper than
the etf
so a big point etf to us the assets
would come from the advisors
they would also love the fact that this
is somehow in a prospectus
it's official gives them a little
feeling of like okay i'm covered here
the sec understands this
um the top level there are probably
would only use the etf for
its liquidity once it gets liquid like
the way it uses gld
um so that level is harder for us to
read because those people are probably
already buying bitcoin on their own
i don't know james you have any comment
on that but i just wanted to sort of
clarify and that advisor level by the
way
um bitwise just did a survey although
it's in their self-interest
i think they the numbers are close to
this like 63 said they would rather have
an etf
and that was like i think only 16 said
direct so that gives you an idea of that
level
they really like the convenient aspect
of it and the way it would just fit
right in a portfolio like a puzzle piece
with the rest of their etfs and funds
yeah the only thing i would add is you
talked about god being he's like there's
gbtc's volume is crazy like gbtc for an
otc product to be trading as liquid
with tightest with as the spreads as
tight as they are um
it's it's it's also being used by some
some heavy hitters for sure
um and then yeah and if you look at
kathy wood
i mean that's what she has used to get
exposure
um i mean she's in a fun she's buying
that but in very small doses but
um but yeah the volume still is like
what is it under a billion
it's about a million yeah so you
probably have a little institutional
dabbling in that um but if you got a
bitcoin etf
i'd imagine you'd see this thing trade
five to five billion a day at least the
one one of them usually gets chosen as
like the one and
that's why they're all in a race because
if you're the one in this case this is
the biggest
race for for an etf prize i've ever seen
in my life you know i use the metaphor
of the movie the cannonball run
i don't know i'm i'm gen x i'm not sure
if you know that music but it's like a a
race from
it's a from new york to la and whoever
gets there first gets like a million
dollars
there's something very similar here and
they know it and
it could even really affect their
business if they get approved or don't
get approved and
that race has been it you know
fascinating to watch
how big second largest gold
etf so there's gld which is the winner
do we know how big the
second largest one is sure i think it's
about
it's pretty big so see here's here's
going to happen here's what happens with
all etfs the first one that gets
approved
is probably going to charge let's just
say 1.5
and it's going to get a bunch of volume
um in the case of gold
the biggest one gld has 70 billion the
second biggest one has 31 billion
yeah it's pretty good it charges um 25
bips whereas gld is 40 bips
so usually the liquid one has pricing
power it doesn't need to cut fees the
new guy comes in and we call it
vanguarding the category by coming in
cheap
it's like walmart coming into town
they'll come in and undercut them
and then what's going to happen is
advisors are cost obsessed
so the long-term money will probably go
to that one so
iau is used by more buy and hold but gld
will still retain
the trading crowd because they don't
they're going in short term the expense
ratio is an annual fee so it means less
if you're in it
for a smaller period yeah and then um
if it's so there also is other gold etfs
that have come in even cheaper than iau
multiple of them actually this launched
the guy who launched this
stage street who launched gld actually
launched like a mini version
that's super cheap basically so they
don't take away from the money they're
getting in gld they have one that
charges
i think it's around 15 basis points or
something like that um
so there's all these games that are
being played and the same things kind of
happened in the trust space so i
mentioned bitwise is launching a
fund that's going to compete with gbtc
their expense ratio they're saying is
going to be about 1.5
grey scales is 2 uh earlier last month
we saw
osprey bitcoin fund it's a it's another
trust that's launching
their management fee is 49 basis points
there's going to be some other fees in
there
there's it's not clear exactly what the
full expense ratio is so management fee
is one portion of what the full costs
are going to be
but there's already this cost
compression coming into the market and
as
more things get launched uh if an etf is
approved it's going to bring down the
cost that you have to pay custodians
like fidelity
um and legal fees and all these
different stuff to get these things
launched
yeah it's fascinating to hear that in
the uh the gold
kind of etf world people literally
launching multiple ones and almost
competing with
themselves as a way to kind of continue
to get more and more market share
it's like cannibal as they they're
cannibalizing themselves so they don't
lose all the money
well it's sort of like we talked about
the beginning like gbtc would they
launch a new one
because that gbtc is a cash cow right um
gld charges 40 bips and it's liquid
and the people who that liquidity you
can't buy liquidity it grows organically
like a tree
so if you have liquidity we call these
etfs diamonds if your etf trades more
than 50 million dollars a day
you are you and you're sitting pretty
because you don't really have to lower
your fee so what happens is and i shares
did this too eem was trading like a ton
charges 69 basis points and vanguard
started eating
away at it with its like 20 basis point
bwo
so in order to fight vanguard it
launched iemg
at about the same vanguardian fee so it
sort of
cloned eem in in order to just deal with
the advisor market
that way it didn't hurt the cash cow
over here and since then
in the clone area they've now they're in
a fee war
that's pretty intense schwab gets
involved and all of a sudden the fee war
of etfs that's become pretty famous
kicks in so i would imagine some of that
would happen in the bitcoin world as
well
although at a higher level i'm not
expecting a 10 basis point bitcoin etf
anytime soon
yeah it makes sense uh before we go to
wrap up uh i ask everyone the same three
questions i've never done it with two
people so we'll uh i'll just kind of
throw it out there and we'll fire away
uh the first question is just what's the
most important book each of you has read
um you know there's two books i've read
twice
i mean besides the bible i'm i'm you
know pretty christian and the bible to
me is
if you really read the bible there is so
much more going on than what you think
and it's
filled with something there's energy in
there and i really like it it's like
eating health food besides the bible
that's maybe a boring answer
i've read two books twice one is
confederacy of dunces
a hilarious comedic book written about a
guy
it's all he wrote he shoved the book
under his bed and then he committed
suicide so it's this book that god taken
and it's brilliant i can't believe
they've made a movie about it yet but
it's a real
fun funny book about just a it's just a
great character and then the other one
is bob dylan's chronicles
um it's basically a book that takes
place from his childhood until right
when he hit in 1963 with blown in the
wind it ends right there
but it's really his life in new york as
um you know 20
not god's 18 year old and just how he
collected the information that ended up
going into those lyrics
and it's really a great if you look if
you want to know like how to get idea
flow going um read that book
he tells you how he because you re
listen some of dylan's songs
and they're mind-blowing it's like how
did this guy write all this at age 21
and the book kind of lets you into how
he did it and it's
uh really you can apply it i think it's
a great book i love that answer
james uh i'll go with something more
recent i mean i
so two two examples uh bad blood by john
kyru which talked about
uh what happened uh with elizabeth
holmes and
uh i'm blanking but it's theranos and
you could you just saw the absolute
fraud that happened
under everyone's noses and that really
just opened my eyes to like
how like easily manipulated and
manipulable
things can be um so i i love that book
and i couldn't get enough of it
um so i'll go with that one as a recent
read
awesome okay second question uh it's a
little bit more personal
uh this comes from the folks over at
eight sleep they've got like a
thermoregulation
bed uh that allows you to basically
sleep in a really cold environment it's
supposed to make you sleep better i
sleep with it every night it's amazing
uh what is your guys sleep schedule and
uh what's really interesting here is
like the traditional markets have hours
of operation
so they kind of shut off and you can you
know stop paying attention kryptos 24
7. so what is this something where you
guys are sleeping five six hours or are
you guys more like eight nine hour
sleepers
um okay i'll start i i try my best to
get eight
um i i have this mathematical theory and
it's a formula that i think should be
it's my equals m c squared if you're
well rested
two hours feels like one if you're tired
one hours feels like two
i swear to god that should be put into
science books because
um and the key for me is i need about
seven
at least seven to get well rested so i
try to get to bed before 10 15.
as 10 30 11 hits then i get the second
wind and then i and then i'm really
messed up so i it's like
i kind of have to crash early and
reading a physical book is
is how i do that it really like makes me
drowsy
i've got so mine has completely changed
so i used to get seven hours almost like
every night when i was going into the
office but i've gotten in this
i guess it's kind of a bad habit since
i'm working from home every day where i
just don't sleep as much as i should or
like i'm i log
on to my work computer at night at like
10 11 o'clock at night because something
happens on twitter i'm like oh i should
get this ready to write this out um so
my sleep pattern has definitely it i
need to solidify it it's a problem for
mine but i
if i don't get i can function on six
hours for a couple days but if i don't
get another
like nine hour day or seven and a half
hour day after that at some point i
i just don't function properly and it
hurts my work and just
everything so yeah i was one of these
people who uh
barely slept i was flying all around the
country doing all this crazy stuff and
then eventually i started to sleep
oh wow this is what it feels like like
being well-rested kind of eric's point
is a much better way to be
uh last question for you guys and you'll
get to ask me one to finish up
is a more fun one aliens are you a
believer or a non-believer
in aliens i'm a believer they're out
there
same eric no no question
i don't know i i they're nowhere near us
i i if they are
it's it's in like another multiverse or
something like it's
because the odds of the sun and the and
this hitting a certain planet
exactly that i don't know i i'm
skeptical
i'll say that i think you're right in
that they
uh one they exist but two is i like the
theory that like they're so far away
from us and everything that you see in
the sky is you know millions of years
old or whatever so like
we'll just never get to that right we'll
never communicate we'll never actually
reach them but
uh the odds from just the expansiveness
of the universe being so big
uh is high
speaking of which here's a question if
you want to get deep
the question that i love is
why is there something rather than
nothing or
what is the universe expanding into
if you ask elon musk it's a simulation
and uh when we don't get out of this
game we're all going to be like damn we
were dumb
i've got i've got two questions for you
one one more
on the topics and one a little more
personal also on topic um
a lot of crypto guys like heavy into
crypto uh
don't believe there should be an etf
they're like against rehab athlecation
or any of those things what is your
opinion on these funds that are
launching and do you think there should
be an etf approved
yes i think that it's just an inevitable
thing like forget like what
our opinions are right it's more so just
like of course there's going to be an
etf at some point
uh if you go ahead and you look at like
gbtc
or bitw like all of these funds
they serve as marketing functions for
the industry um and
basically if you want to get exposure
like the lightest exposure you'll get is
you'll come into those funds
and then eventually people would say
well like what else can i do or how else
can i get exposure and you kind of
trickle down
from that public market fund to
something else uh
simultaneously actually some people will
buy it personally like on the crypto
exchange and then
professionally try to go get exposure
into a funk because they have to
uh but i just think that like it doesn't
really matter like do we want it or not
like it's gonna happen
um and so it's better time spent like
just trying to figure out what's the
impact of that when it does occur
uh more so than like somehow advocating
like that the sec should prevent
it from ever happening of course it's
gonna happen the next one is your
twitter habits
what percentage so you're obviously
extremely intelligent you know what
you're talking about
what percentage of your tweets which you
say are completely trolling
hyperization of what you actually think
versus versus real thoughts
because some of it is out there yeah
what's your true percentage
yeah so the the people that i like to
troll
uh are def like there's definitely some
times where i like say something and i
know that like
a peter shift or like some guy like
an absolute aneurysm reading it like
just being like are you kidding me
uh but no i would say like you know when
i really sit down and like behind closed
doors if i have a conversation with
someone they're like what do you really
think is going to happen
uh like broadcast probably said 90 like
i really do believe that
uh we are going to see like a massive
massive uh disruption here
uh i liken it a lot to um kind of the
analog world we had kind of pre-70s or
80s then we transitioned to this like
electronic q-sip world
right where every asset is now on
electronics up whether it's cash stock
you know whatever it is uh and so like
we think of that as like a technology
transition but really that was the
foundation for
really the global financial system today
right like imagine if you still had an
open outcry method on
uh the stock market like gamestop robin
hood like none of that stuff would
happen
right and so i think that just like now
moving to this digital world
um is going to be pretty uh disruptive
the one thing that i do
think people don't spend enough time on
is a lot of people like to look at the
new technology and then apply it
backwards right they're basically
looking at it and they're saying hey
like how do we improve uh publicly
traded stocks using blockchain
technology
and like there will be iterative
improvements and i do think that there
will
uh kind of be innovation and progress
there but to me the the
part that i really really believe in i
think is more intellectually interesting
and probably the part that like you know
some people look at it like oh you're
just trolling
uh is i actually look at this like this
crypto native world
so what happens to the person who like
they never touch a single
legacy asset right they literally just
they get paid in digital
uh currency they sit and they hold all
these tokens that have on chain cash
flow they're streaming payments like
kind of like this like utopian world
i don't know what the time frame is uh i
don't think it's gonna happen tomorrow
but like
20 25 years from now like i actually
think that we're all
underestimating how disruptive this will
be and so it's
uh some element of like by tweeting
about it uh i get to say like i told you
so
20 years from now or 10 years from now
uh but there's definitely
a while where like you know you just
fire it off and i literally know there's
people freaking out and it just i kind
of chuckle to myself and go about my day
uh and every once in a while they'll
actually email me like that's when i
know i really struck a chord as like
when somebody
reads something on twitter and then
takes the time to go email me
and be like i can't believe you said x
and i'm like all right well that hit uh
that hit the bullseye
so uh i'll keep that in the back of my
head to reuse for uh first six months
from now
yeah i've read some of your tweets and
i'm like there's no way he actually
fully believes this
he's do you remember someone is gonna
have a stroke i don't remember one of
them
oh man i wish that you uh you had one i
should actually
debate the marriage they're probably
they're probably some uh
derivative of the have fun staying
poorer mindset
which by the way um here's a question
for you i'm not sure if you'll answer
this but
when you think of somebody who is really
this optimistic on crypto
and has sort of made their career out of
it when it comes to your like when you
you know i don't do you have kids i i
don't
well let's say you had like couple kids
uh you start building for retirement
you've got their college fund
do you put all that in crypto or do you
go and you do like a
a normal 401k with some mutual funds or
etfs or
what have you like how do you know
that's a fantastic question
uh i think it's even harder to obviously
if you just say like hey if you're an
individual like whatever as you start to
put more and more parameters
you know so are you married do you have
kids what's your risk appetite you know
what's your current net worth what
income do you have how many revenue
streams
like you can kind of really play this
out as to try to come up with like the
perfect solution for an individual
person
but i think just in a general basis uh
the way that i
look at it is um there's kind of three
separate strategies one is there's
definitely like speculative bets right
so whether you look at bitcoin as a
speculative bet or you look at you know
kind of
the 299th uh token on coin market cap
that's absolutely probably
nonsense but maybe it doubles and you
know you get lucky uh there's
speculation the second thing is uh i'm a
big believer in
the folks who are early to the
transition from analog assets to
electronic qsup assets they were still
buying the same asset they were buying
it from the same counterparty just new
technology form factor
and so there was greater returns right
uh for some period of time before they
got commoditized
so if you look at something like maybe a
block five uh cash account where you can
earn up to eight point six percent apy
it's still dollar exposure now there's a
little bit of rehybridication there's
some risk you gotta underwrite it all
that kind of stuff
but compared to the legacy electron
accusative dollar interest bearing
account like
it's so much better it's so much higher
return uh and so i think that that's
like
less speculation more just you're being
kind of innovative and understanding it
and then the third thing is just like
hey if everything blows up and like
it literally goes to zero which i think
is very very low probability but just
say like
literally all of this blows up like you
better not have a hundred percent
exposure
right especially as you get older as you
have kids they need these other
responsibilities
and so i think that uh really finding
the balance is kind of on an individual
basis
uh but i just don't see uh that many
people who are older with kids who have
a lower risk
tolerance i don't see them going 100
right
there's a lot of 22 year olds i know
just being in the space that
they're they're like 150 percent in like
their entire liquid network
their illiquid net worth is in and their
time is invested 100
in it so they're like all in yeah i
think
i think the debate is out on whether or
not this fits into a portfolio i mean
one percent five percent whether you're
an institution or individual like it the
debate is out as far as i'm concerned
the quantitative benefits of holding
some sort of crypto assets at this point
um so yeah that's one to five percent
makes you sound uh rational
james right the the 99 that somebody i
didn't say that's where i was but
i'm saying at least at least one percent
makes complete sense as somebody
for an individual i'll leave you guys
with this uh
cz from binance the uh the founder and
ceo of binance
uh for whatever reason uh it's come
become this running joke that whenever
the price drops and i'll say something
like you know hey i bought more bitcoin
he'll always respond to me and say i
didn't i have no more fiat left
he was a former bloomberg employee
actually he used to work at bloomberg
yeah
yeah yeah he's fantastic um can i just
can i just just one quick thing one more
question
all the wall street bets going on i get
the sense that crypto
i find crypto's reaction to it
interesting i find two different
reactions one is
um oh you think our market's manipu
manipulatable
um that's one which is which we in etfs
are kind of having that reaction too
it's not us and then the other reaction
is sort of this like
oh guys dude we're come with us
we're we're really on a much bigger kick
okay we're looking
and i almost feel like you're looking at
them as new recruits is that
you guys are trying you guys are trying
to short squeeze wall street we just
took our ball and we're going to play
elsewhere like come play our game our
game is way more fun
my favorite part is uh uh i i guess
they'd be okay
so like obviously the wall street bets
moderators uh when all this happened you
know they're kind of scrambling to
figure out like what happened uh how
should they react
what you know media is calling them like
all this kind of stuff and so i had the
opportunity to talk to a couple of them
and uh and one of them literally said to
me crypto
24 7 question mark like like his eyes
like lit up he was just like
24 7 markets like let's go it's 24
7 it's got an anti-establishment
populism vibe
i mean it's kind of a it seems like a
whole they're gonna
it'll be a home for some of them after
they sort of maybe figure out they're
paying all these trading costs
people are holding the bag crypto seems
like a natural space for them
i think that's exactly what's going to
happen so where can we send people to uh
to find you guys on the internet
or or find more of your work
uh so you know we're on the term if
you're on the terminal bi etf if you
have a bloomberg terminal if you don't
where you can find me
in in the wild is on twitter at eric
balchunus it's just my name that one
wasn't taken
shocker um and you can also look up
trillions podcast
which i co-host with joel weber of
businessweek and that's available
anywhere
yeah i'm also on twitter um at jsafe so
j-s-e-y-f-f
um and we're like eric said we're both
very active on twitter we get a lot of
our feedback and ideas so
tweet back out of us send us a dm uh we
love the feedback awesome guys listen
thank you guys so much for taking the
time to do this i learned a lot i think
everyone else will as well
and i'll have to do it again in the
future